bruit vibration perturbation liée aux
travaux et abattage des arbres à la
liste des griefs contre le passage de la
deuxième ligne de tramway par le
boulevard Jean Royer semblait bien
longue mardi soir une réunion
d'information avait lieu au stade pour
présenter le tracé bilan dériverains
mécontents et encore beaucoup de
questions sans réponse Faustine Luneau
la salle est comble trop petite pour
accueillir tous les tours enjaux venus
assister à cette réunion publique dans
l'assistance une grande majorité
d'habitants inquiets voire en colère
face au tracé de la future ligne B du
tram
on a expliqué la salle de cinéma
ambiance tendue les questions et les
remarques sont nombreuses principales
points de crispation le boulevard Jean
Royer sur lequel passera la ligne
364 jours par faut m'expliquer comment
vous allez pouvoir
drainer toutes ces véhicules si vite
véhicules vous aviez boulevard Jean
Royer par ses axes de vote et rucher la
Renault vous reportez promises qu'en
est-il des vibrations qu'elles ont été
les calculs qui ont été effectués les
habitants du quartier sont vend debout
contre le projet il juge la rue trop
étroite et craignent de voir le tram
passer à 3 mètres de leur fenêtre des
craintes que n'ont pas su apaiser les
élus beaucoup de points sont encore
inéclaircies en attente d'études
supplémentaires l'impression que ça
donne c'est que les conclusions sont
déjà connues sans même la fin des études
donc quand on pose des questions on aura
les réponses plus tard mais par contre
la conclusion elle elle est connue c'est
possible le maire de Tours et l'équipe
du syndicat des mobilités de Touraine
ont pourtant tenté de répondre à toutes
les questions on est très attentif à vos
craintes on continuera à chaque étape de
ce projet à répondre aux questions et à
organiser ces moments
de discussion qui sont vraiment
nécessaires pour que le projet soit
accepté par l'ensemble de la population
sachant que c'est un projet pour 50 ans
un projet dont le budget s'élève à 503
millions d'euros les travaux devraient
débuter en 2025 pour une mise en service
en 2028 selon le syndicat des mobilités
de Touraine 35 000 voyageurs par jour
sont attendus sur cette deuxième ligne